hi you have this is a
Sadashiva pie from science mission we
have dr. avatar
Rhys with us today he is the professor
in the Department of Biological Sciences
in the University of Toledo at Ohio
United States so dr. Avadon Rhys has won
several awards and grants I'm going to
mention only a few of them because it
may take forever to do all the grants
and have RCS one in 2016 he won NIH ro3
so in 2017 he won faculty member of the
Council of unesco international self
research organization in 2018 john dee
and julius jacobson endowed
professorship in biomedical research
he's also editorial member and reviewer
for several journals welcome doctor can
you please talk about your background
education and some of the work you are
doing please yeah so my background is
that position for my career so I really
start with with asking questions in my
very early education about fascicular
transport in fusion and then as I move
up with my career I move more to ask
questions of opiate addictions and then
I really did a big transition to fly
genetics and as you are going to hear
today we're actually now moving forward
to ask questions that are related to the
human condition and hopefully we hope to
move into more clinical aspects so we
only make doing from very basic
mechanisms to kind of a general more
clinical aspects and can you please talk
to me about talk to us about your lab
lab people grad students enter so
the lab is based on PhD students right
now we have 5 PhD students they work
closely with many under guard so our
papers are usually our time of a tip
walk we also collaborate with a lot of
people outside of our university our
research is very collaborative we are
really benefitting for mochi with many
other people in the scientific community
okay and how do you motivate them
because these are all small cage trying
to get their research going as you know
research is up and down all the time
yeah well you know one of the thing that
people that were in science for a long
time can do they can in perspective and
I think that's what needed to be done we
do a lot of things it's you know the
keys to keep it exciting there isn't I
go up and down but you collaborative
other people you interact right you
write reviews if things are down about
search so we do many things so when
things don't go very well to your
project you are also working as a team
so people have their own project they
lead but they also participate in a team
of other people so based on where are
you in your project and how things are
going we are kind of making sure that
you have all the time engaged and there
are something positive going on okay
that's good and can you please talk
about some of the role models and
mentors in your career so I in my career
I had actually three very different
mentors in my master and I did my master
I had a mental doctor Daphna atlas she
was really it was fun because we've had
we just speak for hours on models and
ideas and it was very exciting time as a
young pair so then I moved to do PhD
with dr. Trafalgar in the Weitzman
Institute in Israel and he was really a
guy that were fairly he was very
strategic he did things very organized
with able to do to publish many paper at
that time because he was such an
organized guy and he always was thinking
about how do I make sure thermal care
here is okay so I learned from him how
to look on the projection of where the
students will go and make sure that they
are moving ahead correctly and then I
my postdoc with dr. Luke a new series DP
and this was really a very exciting time
because this lab will be made many major
discoveries on different things and I
learned from him also to look on Liddy
on the high impact things you know you
want to make him high impact finding
take a high risk because there is a high
game don't only walk on the what is a
shoe bed know and coming back to you
were like I know you are busy with all
your research and all those things how
do you have this work-life balance what
are your hobbies and other interests
other than the research science I hope
you that is kind of it's a bit strange
but I I really like to read about
history beyond the eye on stage in the
Middle East I'm really excited by this
transition in the human history and I
read a lot about this ecology but I
really more kind of fair I would say
quite a single-minded person science is
my top priority
okay that's good so now let's talk about
your research and how do you get into
all this developmental biology and you
know charles yukl lab there's a lot of
development or biology stuff so can you
please talk about your research and
present your work yes so you know a key
thing about research is that we use all
modern technology of molecular genetic
microscopy but if I need to define a
feature that is really a kind of unified
all our research is that we do look on
comparative biology we look on many
organism and also in my presentation
that they're going to see the field
shifting for many animals and we try to
compare between them and we try to
understand why changes happen along
evolution and then provide a molecular
explanation for that so that's kind of
our approach we would like to go look on
many organism we like to do the very
basic one we also like to do and take it
to the clinical and the human and the
medical so we are really kind of having
but we try to get both benefits the
basic research the interesting biology
but also the human connection
yeah we saw you at a recent paper which
is pretty interesting so can you please
talk about it by your three-year
presentation thank you so okay so I will
shift to my presentation then and you
tell me if you see it do you see it now
yeah guys okay very good so so this is
really just kind of a emphasizing again
our approach from basic research to
translational through a comparative
approach I will not repeat that you know
they're kind of the basic basic question
that we are trying to undress right now
in all this is because research do move
and change quite a lot through the last
ten years but the current major question
is when we start our life how do how
does it the beginning happen then we all
know it start with a sperm and an egg so
what is the relative contribution of
those two structures to those cells to
the first cells at the beginning of our
life design God and we all know that the
DNA come from both the mother and the
father and action there are many many
structures and I think the most famous
one is the man to come hear that coming
from the mother only most of what we
have in the beginning to support life
come from the mother
but there is one structure that coming
exclusively from the father and this is
this structure coded same to y'all and
let me just explain shortly what is its
into y'all so here you see a picture
with many organelles that the seller you
cannot Excel him and we are going to
focus on this to structure that I really
found at the center of the cell at least
in cells that a certain stage and these
structures these two structure have a
very unique organization they are made
of 90 bit of microtubules and those mega
tumors already the signature of this
structure this form how people define
them and here you could see on the top a
cross-section what unit cell biology
will use to ask the question do I see a
Cynthia you will see this nine triplet
microtubules and that would be the
definitive element okay I'm looking on
its entry oh we
until a quite big structure like the
size of 200 nanometer by half a
micrometer they almost the size of a
small bacteria a they are surrounded by
this material hearing that the PCM which
then act as a mechanism to create a
sterile microtubule basically creating
what we call it simple zones so the Sun
usually have it simple so much acting as
a microtubule organization center it
simply all does have a unique double
life the ideal format centrosome like we
saw here but usually when a cell until G
1 in the cell cycle
it simply all will move to the surface
of the cell and the order of them will
become the main basal body will form a
flagella or cilia which is a very
important for cell movement but also for
sensory function usually as a cell move
on the city will dissolve and will
regain the central zone but usually
function during cell division the key
thing that for from this presentation
from this slide to go to understand
about what I'm going to say today is
that the cell dividing cell have to set
the other name and when I say - I mean
precisely - not 1 and not 3 and those
simply all are structurally defined
based on the presence of microtubule and
they have this unique shape of a barrel
shape
this is a typical sent to your what I'm
going to show you soon is that they
actually exception to that a because
simply your number is so important cell
must have to turn to yours and the two
things will actually be different from
each other we call them a mother in a
total these two centrioles need to
duplicate and then when after the cell
duplicate then then they are precisely
segregated such each daughter cell have
to and this is the basic mechanism how
our cells make sure that every cell have
this ëismí - so kind of the key question
that we are asking is okay through our
development if you have a cell that have
two and then we develop it the cell d5
become folded right to two and this is
happening again and again that's all
gate but how the beginning how the
zygote or the first cell obtained it
stood sent to your
and this is not trivia it's a trivial
because one of the interesting phenomena
is that for example they meet you egg
have no time to use the egg provides
Xerox into yours so how do we inherit
this other the to TMT or if the egg does
not have it the answer is really spam
and here you could see a kind of a the
skeleton of evolutionary tree and you
could see that many animals in the many
puzzle animals head in there a spam to
centrioles which indicated here and if
you have put something in the sperm and
Zeile sent the oil in the egg you have
to simply roll and everything is okay
the zygote can start its life and
anything moving ahead but here's the
problem
if you look on mammals like humans for
example we have only one recognizable
centriole in the Spill the same thing
actually happening insects they have
only one recognizable scent to y'all
based on structure and there is actually
something much more weird in mice where
you could see there is we can we can
really recognize we cannot recognize and
it's until also the dogma is that there
is not simply all see the my spell so
how do we go from 1 + 0 to 2 that's
basically the kind of a major question
that we are asking those days and just
to reiterate the question I want to
mention a phenomena called Sentosa
production and this phenomena is
important because this is a phenomena
that will take an egg precursor cell or
germ cells which help to centriole and
eliminate them so the egg cells at the
end of the process of maturation will
have 0 centrioles
in the sperm the common concept or dogma
in the field is is that you start with 2
like every other cell then through the
process of central dome adduction you
lose one of the simply holes and you're
left advanced into y'all and then
somehow in a mechanism that people
propose that maybe if we have an
centrioles and to know how to duplicate
then you will get to send to yours and
that's of the problem but this idea
actually was never tested it was an idea
that it was accepted because it makes a
lot of sense but no direct evidence to
that exists and i
- basically challenge that idea I'm
going to propose an alternative
mechanism and this all started actually
about nine years ago when we have
studied it's in to yours in flight so
that's it now so here you could see
there how really getting to the question
from the basic mechanism at that time we
were asking basic questions about what
Central Hudson to yellow form we have
identified an important call Anna won
GFP that was a lady named Anna won by
other one it's OD product it's a simply
all-important but labor or simply or
that was discovered just around that
time and this 14 was fused to again flow
is important and you could see here the
fly test is really labeling audit
centriole if we magnify and we look here
to the area of the stem seller the
number one exist you could see that
there are two centriole in the cell and
one of the interesting thing about the
fly is a decent you'll actually go
become very long so we could actually
see them very clearly if we look on
expenses for example here you could see
the nucleus in blue that centriole in
green and the sperm tail in red you
could see that indeed there is one
single sentry all this is post meiosis
after meiosis the early spermatid this
family the cell that will become the
spermatozoa of the differentiation of
one central and this is what was known
for decade for by the work of many many
scientists but one thing that we noticed
is that the second one thing that we
notice is that there is as we go and
during the development we see in
addition to dis line a small bump and
then if we follow this bump little bit
later it actually move away and it is a
non intent ax T and actually here you
could see on the top on the right
carnival number seven that every long
simply y'all have this tiny thing so
what is this tiny thing just just to
kind of make the story short this tiny
thing is what we call an atypical simply
or which I'm going to explain a little
bit what do I mean by that
so we call it sentry all because if you
look on a variety of central you're not
14 they are all
this entity so this is a structure that
even though was not recognized before it
actually contained many of the simply or
specific bottoms when we do electron
microscopy and a on this entry on you we
could see here this is the language
simply all that have this nine mic
youtubers but then you could see that
there is this spirit center yellow
material which is very dark in the
insects and then you could see this
entity that does not have microtubules
and if you do a cross-section of that
you could see that it's actually made of
a electron dense wall with a central
structure inside the central tube and
here on the side you could see
microtubule by the way and you could see
called compare the size this is really a
tiny structure and here is a model of
that send to your based on our
structural studies and just for
comparison here is an ohm and simply
also normal simply all is 200 nanometer
by 500 nanometer this structure is only
100 nanometer by 100 nanometer it does
not have microtubule so this structure
was living observed in the past by
people because it looks so differently
also beyond that we need to use really a
special type of electron microscopy high
pressure freezing precipitation to be
able to see because when you do regular
chemical fixation it's very hard to see
it and I think that's the reason it was
missed in the past so okay so there is
this entity what is it doing and we'll
follow it a post cell division so we
fertilize a sperm with an anode side of
experiment then we looked what happened
during meiosis so this is a single this
is the first cell this is the zygote you
see here the DNA in the middle you see
the spin microtubule and you see
beautiful
centrosome in both sides if we focus on
the center of one of them you could see
here the Long Center y'all and you can
see actually another dotted central your
nearby we know this is a dotted simply
on that was formed in the egg because
the way we the experiment is constructed
is that a we are using an antibody that
is a labeling a protein expressed from
the mother side
and we can see on the other side that
there is two small centrioles a one of
them is labeled by green and this is
again because the way we constructed is
that we are labeling at Porton again
flow is important that is coming from
the mother side and we could follow it
so these two purple structures coming
from the father what one is a very long
one look at them to y'all and we
presumably presume that the other one is
the are typical central and these two
new entities are really a dotted central
form in the zygote so not support the
idea that this pampa by to structure its
entry on and then these are typical
central a next we wanted to ask the
question what is the function of these
are typical simply odd and what we have
done we have done a genetic screen to
identify mutants that have defect in
this a typical centrioles so here you
could see a label out centriole when we
label it by an again with the spot in
ana one with the label at centriole and
our typical centriole and then we have
identified a mutant that have only the
regular centriole but they are typical
central is largely affected in it's very
hard to see so this was a defective
artifical simply on what we can do now
how we can take these two flies each in
a time and fertilize a normal egg and
ask what is happening so when you use a
normal male as i show you before you're
going to get in the zygote put simply or
on each side and DNA in the middle and
however if you fertilize with this fly
that have no a typical centriole we get
3 times monopole of spindles and the
other pole is missing this suggests that
our typical centriole is actually
essential in function during the zygotic
the first i go to the division a after
doing those studies that basically
demonstrated that in the fly there is
these are typical central structure and
these are typical central circle is
inherited to disinter to as I got any is
essential in the zygote we want to ask
the question is this is a general thing
or is this just a fly thing and here you
can see a small study that we have done
in beetles and when we have business was
fought for long
to have only one centriole but when we
stand again with this antibody against
this Ana one protein we suddenly see a
second simply hola structure a typical
structure and we actually can do em and
show it have a very similar dimension as
the are typical sent to all of the
flights I have a nanometer by a hundred
and o meter by electron microscopy so
this led us to the hypothesis that in
addition to the typical centriole insect
in general provide also a second a
typical centriole that look very
different but it can do what it simply
all do and a substitute for it so the
next question after we have done and
this basic research in the fly and we
are continuing asking many questions the
questions how the okapi cuts into your
is form and how does it function if is
so different one thing that we wanted to
ask is okay we've just shown here on the
left side that the Flies and the beetle
have actually put some tools very much
like the main core of the illusionary
peek well then one would hypothesize
that maybe there is also a typical
centriole in each one of us maybe our
sperm the human sperm the normal sperm
have one simply all we recognize and
another one that is waiting to be
identified so we have went forward to
ask this question but first I want into
this you what was the dogma in the field
what is they what is they how what
people believe before that so as I told
you every cell start his life or almost
every cell start with two centrioles in
the mammalian system we call one simply
all that knew the nucleus Cox image sent
to your pc and the one that is further
away we call distantly of and the
disentangle is the one that will form
the flagellum and it is attached to it
it's physically attached templating the
formation of flagella
if you look on a McHugh sperm not an
early spermatid but a mature spermatozoa
you'll see only the proximal centriole
and this absence of this add the ability
of seed at the same little the
conclusion that there is a simple Samba
dutch and we have only one cynthia you
can see for example a publish walk that
the pic this a idea here is the nucleus
on the top with the proximal center your
here and you could see that here there
is this white area we've notes into your
so that what a the idea that there is
only one centriole and this disassembler
is reduced to a remnant low to nothing
and does not function post fertilization
so the first thing that we have tried to
do was the first thing we have done is
basically contact many of our colleagues
as them give us tools for Lou constantly
on any protein that was available to any
of our College leach out and everybody
was very nice and gave us those tools
and I'm going to show you just two
categories of our results some
categories like in this case you could
see the nucleus isn't magic related
human spermatozoa you could see there is
one send to y'all and this is exactly
what the dogma said that the gamma said
there is only one send clear and that's
what people have seen before and that's
why they believe that is not one simply
oh but if you look on other poor things
like for example sentry you see clearly
two dots one co-localize with the
proximal sent to y'all and one more
further away which will feed the
category of distance into your actually
we find some proteins that align with
each in this piece that simply all and
we actually for pokeman be made three we
check three independent antibodies come
from three different sources two of them
we generated ourselves and we always see
more token be in this other Cynthia and
just for a short cut we have done it
with many other proteins we have about
nine proteins now that they demonstrate
that there is the second entities here
this next question was to ask where is
this central where is this other thing
because here you could see an e/m again
showing the proximate centriole and this
empty space we call vault and we have
collaborated with John Ranka form NIH
and she do a beautiful quality of light
electron microscopy and when she did
that and she placed the token be gfp
signal you could see that it labeling
one of them what you expect the
approximate centriole but the other
labeling actually labeled below this
empties
it's labeling the tip of the axon and
you could actually see that the magic
cubes here are actually changing their
morphology so what we conclude from that
is that this a typical or distal
centriole is found connected to the base
of the axon name and not where people
expected it to see it in this empty area
so we again went to do this high
pressure free substitution electron
microscopy because we know it give us a
much better picture and when we do that
you could see here they make a cube or
this is a log into the section and you
could see here they make a - but this is
the axon name but then you can see how
this play up and the white arrow here
show you how it's open and become much
more wine and if we do a cross-section
at that level here you could see that
they are microtubules that they are not
organized in a nine-fold microtubule
anymore
so what we're having is again is it a
typical organization of microtubules
they are completely distorted from
normal organization but they are there
and actually we can see them with any
antibody that we have use we use about
four different antibodies against mica
to breathe and we always see them here
this can be seen much more clearly maybe
in this picture which is a super
resolution microscopy a of this a
structure again it's ejaculated human
spermatozoa done in collaboration with
Vito Manila in the University of Toronto
and you could see here again the
proximate sent to your like that area
you could see the axon him and then you
could see those splaying microtubules
the interesting thing is that when you
look on this poteen in this case it's I
think it's poppin' be a but you have
seen it with many other proteins we see
these two balls that are flanking you
see the microtubules and they are
flanking them from the inside I'm not
going to show you but we have done also
storm super-resolution microscopy and we
see a similar results in we have done it
also in the bovine in this case so these
are typical sent your have a very
different organization and it is a model
of this a typical Cynthia so here's just
approximate centriole that maintain the
same organization I just want to
highlight that even though it have the
same organization it is a typical in its
composition so it's not a normal
centriole in that aspect but
actually it's look very much like what
we expect and people can see it but
there isn't a a typical sentry on the
distance and here was not observe is
because he have this unique organization
where the microtubules are disorganized
actually very hard to see them and they
are surrounding this vault area and
there are these two rods made of pokeman
be sent in Polk five and we have another
protein now that we identify at label
the structure and there is this other
pot in that label and of the top so here
we have another are typical simply all
that is exist in the human sperm and
also in other mammals like bovine and
lots the next question was what is the
function of this guy is it really
walking and here we have done a
collaboration with an Miller that is an
expert with a frog egg stock you know
the difficulty that we have is that
there are some legal and ethical
consideration when you do experiment
with human so we were very careful to
follow all those things and what they
have decided to do is to take a egg
extract form a frogs and make a big like
a shake out of it so we are basically
just poking we separate the DNA from the
proteins and we have only the proteins
here and then we take a human sperm and
we use detergent to strip the membrane
out so it's not really alive anymore
and but we don't kill the protein inside
and then we can expose it and ask what
is happening and here you could see this
spam just without if we do not expose it
to extract you could see the new clothes
here you could see the proximal Center
your that this is found just in it if
we're now expose it to the extract we
see that the tip of the axon namely
could gamma tubulin and gamma tubulin is
a marker for the pellets into yellow
material so this is basically mimicking
it's an in vivo sa functional assay to
ask can this distal artifical simply oil
do what the normal center you're doing a
neck
can it recruit then it send to your low
protein PC important like gamma tubulin
which then form a microtubule ester and
as you could see a actually we see much
more equity to the dissident your then
to the proximal center so that was our
first hint that these are typical simply
all is actually functional the next
thing we wanted to do is something in
vivo and to do that we have collaborated
with - a great scientist that only one
of the leaders in the field that came up
the idea of centrosome reduction Joey
Shelton is Kelvin similarly from the
University of Pennsylvania and what you
have decided to do is to study in the in
the bovine because bovine very much like
human is thought to have the same center
your inheritance and you could see here
that when we fertilize an egg with a
bovine sperm we can now stain it and you
could see here the two nuclei and you
could see here the action name that is
labeling the base of that of attach
somehow to Duncan let's zoom on it and
when we Zone on this area we could see
that the action name which is the
flagella of the sperm at the base
actually record 752 752
is it one of the protein that get
eliminated during the simples of
reduction the remodeling process and now
it is being recruited form the egg to
label it and you could see it here also
not only that this we see during
interphase we see the same thing during
mitosis so he could see a beautiful
picture that affair of zygote in mitosis
you have a spindle microtubules pin and
DNA in the middle and we now we can zoom
on we can look on the centrioles on one
side it's a build on the other side
first thing you could see that the
centrosome on this side action is
connected to the axial name of the
Stanton and that's a sign that we
actually have here a typical send to
your functioning and here you could see
magnification of that the action being
leveling and the base of the centriole
so at the base of the axon in with a
typical centrioles parent is actually
functioning by recruiting PCM and
localizing and forming so basically just
kind of summarize our finding these are
typical centriole can recruit PCM like
SEP 152 it can form an ester like you
could see here around I did not show you
but sorry and he can reside today Paul
and actually I did not speak about it it
came only it could also bear in the
formation of a new tutorial so this a
typical simply all behaved
much like a regular simply oh it's just
very different so to conclude our
studies up to now we think that a course
evolution with the exception of minds
that we have not yet looked on in detail
there are two centrioles either two
normal-looking centrioles like in the
most basal all animals but in the insect
there are two because there is one
typical and one are typical and also in
non holden's mammals have one typical
and one article the interesting thing is
the destruction is very different and of
course we are very interested in the
future to understand why this certainty
or become a typical and how they become
a typical because for example one can
think that if there is a defect in the
mechanism that makes it simply all a
typical this may lead to infertility and
we think actually that this will lead to
unexplained infertility because our
prediction is that the sperm look pretty
much normal and if the sperm is normal
and you go to the physician well nothing
is wrong with you but maybe there is
something wrong with you and that can be
an unexplained infertility so if several
ideas that we are trying to explore with
this new structure so just to summarize
the new model that we have puts into
your inheritance so simple sum reduction
happen in the germline but instead of
reduction in the mail
we have remodeling one of the temple you
all become a typical sent to you in the
end yes as much as we understand the two
typical send to your disappear this to
the be constantly on from the male are
inherited to the zygote and they found
each of them form an ester and then they
help in the migration and localization
of the two pinoke lie to form a mitotic
spindle each one of them go to a
different ball one pole will have the
regular central y'all then by then he
will duplicate and informal normal
simply all which week indeed psychotic
bloated sent your but will be a normal
typical simply all and on the other side
the a typical senti all will do the same
thing and we'll have this as I got it
dr. Cynthia and that's by this way we
restore the normal complement the normal
complement of simply or we expect in a
sir
this was funded by a different
organization and I throughout the
lecture I hopefully you saw that people
have contributed to the different aspect
this is really was a work done by PhD
students and postdocs in the lab and
also a by many undergrad here you could
see Rachel Hoffman for example an
example of an undergrad at was in the
lab and many other under God and we
really enjoy the enormous interaction
with many colleagues in our field this
is really very fascinating field
reproductive biology people are very
collaborative and they help us and we
are continuing this kind of a direction
thank you thank you so much it's a
wonderful talk thank you very much I
really appreciate that I don't know if
any viewers have any minds questions or
anything they can type it up basically
I'm just trying to see if yeah there
isn't anything so I mean like you have
explained it in pretty nicely the way it
happens and all those things so this may
be in the future I have one question
like once you have these centrioles
right like after meiosis and how they
move move to the other side so you
showed in the picture that the atypical
one moves is it sure that a typical one
the moves to the other side or like is
there a specific way of they are moving
so you're speaking about the fly
situation yeah hi there is a
reorganization of the area a and yeah I
think this is you know I know know if
you notice that it's this is the
location of the change is species
specific so in the fly they're organized
the way like that but in the beetle they
actually one on top of each other and if
through different if not unit on the
phylogeny of animals really the position
of the center is highly variable what is
not variable is that there is always two
it's also highly variable how they look
so there is a conservation of number but
not structure and not position and
that's there
well with the knowledge about what is
the all of st. Leo's simply odds really
need to maintain number that's a
critical thing and as we get more
knowledge about what is there really the
structure of the temple you'll do then
we understand well maybe it's not
critical a certain stage of the cell
life to have it typical simply all and I
think this is really one of the impact
of this work is that I think people
should consider that in certain cell
types especially differentiated cell
type in a certain sort of start stages
maybe that's in your look a bit
different from what we expect and it's
for the purpose for some biology that we
need to discover and in the atypical
centrioles there is those microtubules
right so they look different
disorganized so do you know why and when
it becomes again reorganized and ah so
that's exactly what we are doing right
now if studies in the fly we are trying
to understand the mechanism and we are
also starting in a mammalian system and
we are just discovered some key player
we think that actually stabilize a new
Genesis it's important to understand
that when it simply the cell this
pyramid itself is round it transition
into this beautiful like moving sperm
during that time there are many many
days of transformation and during that
time there is a major transformation in
the Tempe O's it's a multi-step process
that we can actually image it we can see
it we see an Reitman of poor thing then
they are get distributed so this is
exactly what we are studying right now
we think this is very important we think
this can explain I said almost only
spoke about infertility but I can tell
you that there are other issues like
spontaneous abortions that happened that
may be explained by that because
everybody think this the embryo is okay
but you know in the absence because
simply on the embryo is doing it not
okay and things start to go wrong and
then the embryo will not develop
normally and so we are trying to
understand the mechanism to find the the
whole we think that part of it is really
key protein that are being changed and
there is a new set of protein
in the spam in the fly for example I can
tell you we have shown that there is a
porting that have different to pot in
isoform one isoform go to the are
typical simply on and another spice
isoform go to the typical sensor so it's
the same gene but they have two product
one go to the other Picard simply one go
to the typical so we think this concept
is maybe involved in the generation of
this diversity of Cynthia la strategy
thank you so much I really appreciate it
is wonderful fascinating work and I look
forward to more of your papers in the
near future so you can share the link
with anybody you want to it will be on
our website so good luck again thank you
thank you